let's take a vote and hear from Hunter
Biden what are you afraid of hold on
hold on order order are women allowed to
speak in here or no thank you Mr
chairman uh excuse me Hunter apparently
you're afraid of my
[Music]
words
Mr one objection can we get some order
here Mr chairman where are we in the
okay okay
I'm glad I was at my exercise class and
missed that but the only thing that was
missing at today's house oversight
Committee hearing were three rings and
PT baram himself now the committee
eventually pulled itself together they
moved closer to holding Hunter Biden in
contempt of congress now this entire
thing was orchestrated by his lawyer
Abby Lowel is a political stunt and
political stunt making runs in this
family of political group grifters
joining me now oversight committee chair
James comr um a congressman you know
critics are going to say that this was a
win for Hunter because you know he shows
up and it just devolved into
shouting well I would strongly disagree
with that he showed up uh he was there
for about 15 minutes Moscow witch was
recognized he said Hunter Biden's here
to answer questions and then his time
expired I recognized margorie Taylor
green she was going to ask Hunter Biden
questions because mosit said he was
there to answer questions as soon as he
he realized margorie Taylor green was
going to ask him a question they ran out
of there they knocked over people on the
way out the door so I think the American
people got to see two things number one
he was not there to answer questions and
number two this is the second time that
Hunter Biden has displayed in real time
the arrogance and entitlement that he's
had his entire life uh why he thinks he
can get millions and millions of dollars
from our enemies around the world and
then not pay taxes on it and then lie
about it look this is an investigation
of Joe Biden it's about what his family
did to receive the millions of dollars
from our enemies around the world and we
just have simple questions that we need
to ask Hunter bid deposition there was a
moment where uh again they think they
have you against the wall here and it
was kind of a clever stunt have to say I
think it was kind of clever but this was
a moment where moscowitz tried to turn
the tables on you
watch let's take a vote who wants to
hear from Hunter right now today anyone
come on who wants to hear from Hunter
motion yeah no
one was he unsaved by the Bell that show
he looks so familiar um Congressman why
not leted why not let him speak why not
why didn't you let him speak Moscow it
say well well mosit well look moscowitz
has less credibility than George Santos
had when he was a member of Congress
he's the new George Santos but look at
the end of the day I think the American
people have one question what did they
do to receive the money and all through
the committee this committee lasted
about nine hours today and the Democrats
talked about Trump for eight and a half
hours then they they complained that
Hunter Biden was there to answer
questions but when he was you know
fixing to be asked a question they left
you know when he had the press
conference when we was were supposed to
depose him earlier he said he was there
to answer questions and then after he
read his written statement he got in the
car with Eric swell and drove off he
hasn't answered any questions this is a
sub substantive investigation we've got
thousands of pages of bank records we
have hundreds of specific transactions
that the banks flagged that we have no
idea what they did to receive this money
they don't own real estate they didn't
sell anything they weren't lobbyist yeah
he's very smart he has a lot of
international business experience that
he would he would be paid all these
millions of dollars I'm sure if his last
name you know weren't Biden except we
all know that's not true um Cong
Congressman we appreciate it thank you
so much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else